Не з першої спроби...
…але робочий день таки починається.
До Бородянського району Київщини
реформа екстреної медичної допомоги,
яка передбачає оновлення автопарку швидкої, ще не дійшла,
тож цей російський УАЗ, вироблений 13 років тому
зовсім не для санітарних цілей, продовжує
обслуговувати населені пункти навколо селища Пісківка.
Машина перетворилася на медичну та взагалі
ще їде завдяки водієві Анатолію.
Далеко не кожний ладен отак винахідливо
закріпити проржавілі сходи гумою та залатати дірки
на кузові матеріалами для труб.
- Їздить поки ще.
Шаманимо, та їздить.
Все. Нам же не дають. І двигун самі робили.
Запчастини привезли, розібрали, зібрали
і другий раз - знов потекла олія.
Це 512 бригада швидкої. Фельдшер Олег Черненко,
як і водій Анатолій Хоменко, працюють тут
уже понад 20 років. Фельдшер називає водія Кулібіним.
Каже, без "золотих рук" цього механіка-винахідника
довелося б  надавати допомогу пацієнтові,
однією рукою тримаючи крапельницю, а іншою - ноші з пацієнтом.
- Хоп! І закрив.  Ось так. І витягнув, це коли хворого веземо.
- Це на випадок, якщо двері згниють і відкриються,
щоб людина не випала туди.
Фельдшер Черненко за багато років боротьби
за життя людей в автомобілі, який хитається
на розбитих дорогах, провокуючи, приміром,
передчасні пологи, навчився все сприймати з гумором.
Зокрема й обіцяну та довгоочікувану реформу
екстреної медичної допомоги.
- Показую, як працюється.
- Як працюється?
- Аби було в повний рост…
Треба ставати на коліна і працювати.
Спина болить, усе болить.
Працюється дуже складно, але ми працюємо, слава Богу!
Олег Черненко розповідає, що за час своєї роботи
пережив щонайменше три медичні реформи.
Поки вони тривали, в його бригаді часто не було
ані пального, ані медикаментів.
Ту, що розпочалася два роки тому, він вважає
найбільш успішною. Принаймні, проблем із пальним і медикаментами
більше немає. Здебільшого через те, що всі закупівлі
тепер здійснюються через систему "Прозорро".
Ба більше. Два роки тому тут отримали те, про що
мріяли багато років. Є кисень для важкохворих,
є електрокардіограф. Є й сучасні засоби зв’язку
з усіма медичними базами даних, що суттєво
спрощує щоденну роботу медиків.
У них завжди є нормальний зв’язок
із центральною диспетчерською, яка надсилає
бригаді інформацію без відволікання на телефоні розмови.
- Раніше ми писали купу різних журналів,
а тепер тут усе. Відщолкав усе, передав усе.
Плюс, якщо зняв кардіограмку, сфотографував,
надіслав до центру, лікар подивився.
Все це робиться буквально 5-7 хвилин.
Це круто! Це круто!
Амбітна мета реформи екстреної медичної допомоги
полягає, зокрема, в тому, аби скоротити час приїзду
бригади до 10 хвилин у містах та 20 - в сільській місцевості.
- Добре, дивимося, що в нас за біда трапилася....
Запаморочення, нормальне дихання...
Зв'язок між бригадами медиків і диспетчерськими
мають повністю автоматизувати в усіх регіонах.
Завдяки сигналу GPS диспетчери бачать
місце перебування автомобіля, обирають
найближчий до місця виклику,
передають на планшет вихідну інформацію,
вже проаналізувавши, яка конкретно допомога
необхідна потерпілій особі. У перспективі
диспетчери повинні будуть швидко ухвалювати рішення
і консультувати хворих чи їхніх родичів
увесь час до приїзду швидкої.
У великих містах, зокрема в столиці,
автоматизація диспетчерських триває вже кілька років.
Із 2019-го в Києві і ще п’ятьох регіонах Вінницької,
Донецької, Одеської, Полтавської, Тернопільської областей
у рамках реформи екстреної медицини
запроваджується новий пілотний проєкт.
Він має продемонструвати, як швидко можна
забезпечити всі регіони новими автомобілями
й модернізувати всі диспетчерські, які могли б
працювати як єдиний механізм.
У столиці цей процес суттєво затягнувся.
- Кошти були чималі. Але, на превеликий жаль,
вони не були освоєні,
був тендер заблокований АМКУ,
і всю роботу ми перенесли на цей рік,
і оголошений повторний тендер.
В інших регіонах, за даними Всеукраїнської асоціації
працівників швидкої, невідкладної медичної
допомоги та медицини катастроф, процес закупівлі
і встановлення обладнання теж ще триває.
Поки єдине, що більш-менш виконується за планом,
- це закупівля сучасних автомобілів. Для Києва
придбали 39 авто класу "Б" і класу "С",
які повинні бути укомплектовані на випадок
серйозних масових катастроф. Утім, не всі ці
красиві нові машини використовуються щодня.
- Київ транспортом забезпечений. Дай Боже, щоб
усі області так були забезпечені. Але в нас інша проблема.
Це колосальна кадрова проблема. Ми дійсно
щоденно не можемо укомплектувати
усі заплановані бригади медичними працівниками.
Ми вимушені відмовлятися від цих автомобілів.
Таких відмов у середньому на місяць буває…
50-60 автомобілів не виходить на лінію.
Молоді працівники не затримуються. Здебільшого
працюють люди, яким за 40, каже лікарка
з 30-річним досвідом роботи в київській швидкій Любов Шабаєва.
Жінка дуже радіє новим автівкам та всьому, що всередині.
- Це ноші, на яких можна підняти...
Водночас лікарка не приховує певного розчарування
від медичної реформи. Каже, що очікувала
зовсім іншого результату. Адже реформа
передбачала, що пацієнти укладуть договори
з сімейними лікарями і не викликатимуть невідкладну допомогу,
наприклад, через підвищену температуру чи застуду.
Відповідно в Україні мали б поступово зникати
бригади швидкої допомоги, які обслуговували
такі випадки раніше. Натомість бригади екстреної допомоги
займалися б більш загрозливими ситуаціями
на кшталт переломів, поранень, передчасних пологів тощо.
Планувалося також переформатувати лікарні
таким чином, щоб у них з’явилися багатопрофільні
стаціонари, куди швидкі могли б відвозити людей
для подальшої допомоги. Любов Шабаєва каже,
що всього цього не відбулося. За її словами, наразі
панує хаос, у якому саме бригади екстреної допомоги
дуже часто виконують роботу і сімейних лікарів,
і невідкладної медицини, та ще й витрачають багато часу,
щоб доправити хворого в відповідну лікарню.
- У нас часто буває так, що ми приїжджаємо,
приміром, до нейрохірургії в один стаціонар.
Потім ми перевозимо хворого в інший стаціонар,
у третій. А ми хочемо, щоб у нас були великі
багатопрофільні стаціонари, щоб ми не займалися
перевезенням хворих з одного стаціонару в інший.
Ніби все до цього йде, але я особисто ще не можу
назвати жодного такого стаціонару, який би повністю міг прийняти хворих.
Про створення таких-от багатопрофільних
стаціонарів у регіонах мають відзвітувати
вже у квітні цього року. За даними медичних профспілок,
із  якими поспілкувалася DW, цей процес дуже далекий від завершення.
Немає розуміння у фельдшерів екстреної допомоги
і щодо підвищення зарплат, яке обіцяли в рамках
реформи екстреної медицини. Ось штатні оклади
київських бригад. Жоден не перевищує 5000 гривень.
У сумі не в усіх є навіть 8000 щомісяця.
У сільського фельдшера Олега Черненка зарплатня
з усіма доплатами не перевищує 7000 гривень.
Він лише віджартовується про те, як вдається виживати його родині.
- Дякуючи курочкам і приватному будинку живемо!
512 бригада, яка працює в селищах
Бородянського району Київщини, все ще сподівається, що з квітня
держава виконає обіцянку щодо підвищення
їхньої зарплати до 15 000, нарешті надасть
новий автомобіль, а ще забезпечить приміщенням
для відпочинку між викликами.
За даними незалежних медичних профспілок, нині
такої можливості позбавлені багато бригад не лише
в віддалених районах, а й у великих містах.
Щоправда, Олегу Черненку з бригадою пощастило.
Безкоштовну кімнату їм надала Пісківська селищна
об'єднана територіальна громада. Її керівництво
не лише допомагає бригаді в старому УАЗику,
а й придбало  додатковий автомобіль для виїзду
на виклики до людей похилого віку. Кажуть:
готові допомагати, аби тільки лікарі мали змогу рятувати людей.
Олег Черненко цей обов’язок попри всі негаразди
виконує. Долаючи на старенькому авто
30 кілометрів суцільних вибоїн, він зумів
стабілізувати стан пацієнта до прибуття в лікарню.